la batterie a retrouvé son public
mercredi 19 mai les équipes l'attendait
depuis des mois un spectacle surprise a
été organisée à l'auditorium objectif
fêter la réouverture et marquer le coup
l'événement a été improvisée à la
dernière minute face à l'incertitude
un spectacle d'une heure et demie monter
en une semaine on est dans
l'improvisation c'est vrai d'avenir le
décret sorti que ce matin un nul
permettant réellement et donc oui la
ville à la ville a souhaité marquer le
coup
on a des spectacles par exemple samedi
qu'ils sont qui sont dans la
programmation officielle mais là on
voulait être au rendez-vous de cette
date importante
un spectacle ponctué de rencontres
plusieurs artistes ne se connaissaient
pas avant de faire former ensemble le
jour j le duo marimba danse ils ne se
connaissent pas le trio d'improvisation
générative
on ne se connaît pas musicalement eux
voilà le reste sont des groupes plus ou
moins constituer ou des projets en cours
en tout cas l'idée de rassembler tout ça
sur un seul concert devant un public
complètement improvisé au programme
contes improvisation danse ou encore
ciné concert une douzaine d'artistes
s'est succédé sur la scène dans des
univers est-il à différents c'est le cas
du groupe la brise du mammouth prévenu
une semaine avant et face à
l'incertitude
ils n'ont pu répéter qu'une fois avant
le spectacle les artistes étaient
pourtant ravi de performer à nouveau
devant un public
ça fait plaisir c'est vrai que ça fait
ça fait longtemps donc ça fait un peu
bizarre tout début le premier morceau on
fait un peu rouillé quoi mais ouais
c'est vraiment sympa quoi de pouvoir
rejouer enfin je crois que nous on avait
envie de rejouer mais je pense que les
gens aussi avait envie de le revoir un
peu de groupes en live donc tout le
monde était motivé protocole sanitaire
oblige et la salle a ouvert avec 35% de
la jauge 80 spectateurs ont été
accueillis pour l'événement